DESPERATE SALVAGE OPERATION.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AFTER ANOTHER WEEK OF DELAY IN
THE KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION SAGA
THE FBI SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT IS
IN.
IT APPEARS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE LOST ANOTHER ONE.
>> WHAT WE KNOW FOR SURE IS AT
THE FBI REPORT DID NOT COOPERATE
ANY OF THESE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST
JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> Laura: EVEN THE UNDECIDED
HAMLET FINGER, JEFF FLAKE SAYS
THE REPORT DOESN'T SHOW ANY
COOPERATION WHILE SUSAN COLLINS
CALLS IT VERY THOROUGH.
LET ME SAY AGAIN, THE REPORT,
ALL 46 CHANGES A BIT APPARENTLY
PRODUCED IS ZERO EVIDENCE TO
BACK UP THE ACCUSATION OF HIS
ACCUSERS.
AS WE HAVE COME TO EXPECT,
STRAIGHTFORWARD, FACTUAL
REVELATIONS HAVE ZERO INFLUENCE
ON DEMOCRATS GOING WILD ACROSS
AMERICA.
FOR INSTANCE AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF VERMONT THEY HELD A CANCELED
CLASS, CANCEL BRETT KAVANAUGH
RALLY.
HOW CLEVER.
AND BROOKLYN, NEW YORK, AND
BEL AIR, MARYLAND, THERE WERE
SIMILAR CALLS TO KILL HIS
NOMINATION.
HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C., THE
HATE MACHINE WAS RAMPED UP TO
FULL THROTTLE.
>> OUR DEMOCRACY HAS BEEN
HIJACKED BY THE POWERFUL AND
THEY DON'T PLAN TO SHARE IT.
I AM ANGRY.
LET ME MAKE THIS CLEAR.
I HAVE A PLAN.
>> Laura: BUT -- ISN'T ANGER
MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN BECOMES A
CHANCE?
>> WE ARE.
ABOUT TWO.
MARCH!
>> WE NEED.
>> >> EVERYONE.
>> EVERYONE.
>> TO PAY ATTENTION!
>> Laura: WHO NEEDS CHANCE
THAT RHYME ANYWAY?
WHAT WOULD ANTI-BRETT KAVANAUGH
PRO-ABORTION PROTEST BE WITHOUT
A FEW HOLLYWOOD HEAVYWEIGHTS.
MODEL EMILY SHOWED SOME OUTRAGE
AND SOME MIDRIFF.
COMEDIAN AMY SCHUMER WAS AS
USUAL POLITICALLY UNDERSTATED.
>> A VOTE FOR KAVANAUGH IS A
BOAT SAYING WOMEN DON'T MATTER.
LET'S SAY TOGETHER.
LET'S FIGHT!
LET'S KEEP SHOWING UP!
>> Laura: THE GOOD THING IS
THAT WHEN SHE WAS ARRESTED SHE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T HAVE TO PUT ON
PRISON GARB'S.
SHE WAS ARTIE WEARING IT.
ALL OVER THE CAPITAL THERE WERE
SURVIVORS, COSTING SENATORS
UNDECIDED ABOUT HIS NOMINATION.
THEY ATTEMPTED AT ONE POINT, YOU
WILL LOVE THIS, TO PULL A JEFF
FLAKE AND BULLY SENATORS LIKE
JOE MANCHIN AND TO CASTING A
"NO" VOTE.
>> AS A SURVIVOR I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN LOOK ME
IN THE EYE.
>> HOW ARE YOU NOT LISTENING TO
US?
>> I AM.
>> ARE YOU?
YOU'RE GOING TO GET INTO THIS
ELEVATOR.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO VOTE?
TELL ME!
>> Laura: I LOVE THAT.
STEP BACK.
WHY ARE THEY ALWAYS SAID, LOOK
AT ME?
WE SEE YOU, BELIEVE ME WE ARE
REVERTING YOUR GAZE.
>> THE HARASSMENT TACTICS.
I THINK THEY ARE TOTAL TURNOFF.
AMERICANS JUST DON'T LIKE THE
STUFF.
MOST PEOPLE JUST WANT THINGS TO
CALM DOWN.
>> Laura: THE TRACKING POLL
HAS A PRESENCE APPROVAL AT 50%.
NOT BAD.
A NEW POLL FINDS IT HAD 40%, A
FOUR-POINT GAIN FROM LAST MONTH.
EVEN BETTER, THAT SAME POLL
SHOWS THAT THE SUPERCHARGED
ENTHUSIASM IS ON THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE.
THE DEMOCRATS ADVANTAGE, TANKED!
11 POINTS LAST MONTH, TO JUST
TWO POINTS THIS MONTH.
STILL, THE DEMOCRATS WILL NOT
GIVE UP.
>> THE MOST NOTABLE PART OF THIS
REPORT IS WHAT IS NOT     NOT AN
REPORT IS WHAT IS NOT     NOT AI
REPORT IS WHAT IS NOT     NOT A.
AS WE NOTED BY THE WHITE HOUSE,
THE FBI DID NOT INTERVIEW BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
NOR DID THE FBI INTERVIEW
DR. FORD.
>> GIVEN HOW LIMITED THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE AND HOW LIMITED
THE SCOPE OF THIS INVESTIGATION
WAS, WE ARE REITERATING OUR CALL
THAT THE DOCUMENTS WITH PROPER
REDACTION BE MADE PUBLIC.
WHY SHOULDN'T ALL OF AMERICA
FACTS?
>> Laura: OKAY, I THINK YOU
SHOULD HAVE WORN A WHITE SCARF
FOR SURRENDER.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT WOULD'VE
BEEN MORE APPROPRIATE?
AMERICANS TO HAVE THE FACTS.
DEMOCRATS WANTED A WITCH HUNT
AND IT FIZZLED OVER A LACK OF
EVIDENCE.
THE FACT THAT AMERICANS WILL NOT
FOCUS ON ARE THE ONES HE LEFT
FOR THE MOST.
THE ECONOMIC RECORD OF DONALD J.
TRUMP.
JOBLESS CLAIMS HAVE DROPPED TO A
49 YEAR LOW.
WE NOW HAVE 4.2% GDP GROWTH WITH
PROJECTIONS NOW TO MATCH THAT IN
THE UPCOMING QUARTER.
MANUFACTURING JOBS -- BUT
REMEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID
THEY WERE NEVER COMING BACK?
THEY ARE GROWING AT THE FASTEST
RATE IN 23 YEARS.
TRUMP'S REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
ACTUALLY OFFERING SOMETHING
CALLED RESULTS.
ALSO ONE FOREIGN POLICY, TRADE,
THE AGENDA THAT PEOPLE VOTED
FOR.
MEANWHILE, THE DEMOCRATS OFFER
AMERICANS ONLY THIS.
>> WHY AREN'T YOU BRAVE ENOUGH
TO TALK TO US?
>> DON'T YOU WAVE YOUR HAND AT
ME.
I WAVE MY HAND AT YOU.
>> HOW DARE YOU TALK TO WOMEN
THAT WAY.
>> SENATOR, DO YOU BELIEVE
WOMAN?
>> Laura: IS IT OVER YET?
THERE WE GO.
THE DOOR HAS CLOSED.
DEMOCRATS ARE STILL HOWLING OR
SCREECHING, YOU JUST HEARD THAT.
AGAIN, NONE OF THIS IS A
GOVERNING AGENDA.
IT IS JUST MORE CHAOS,